ben pensato bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj ed oggi siamo tornati su al plus per
chi non l'avesse vista ragazzi consiglio
di vedersi prima la serie a è quella
originale tanto provate annotazioni qua
sopra loro non vedevo l'ora che uscisse
al plus twist global che sarebbe il dlc
che sarebbe il seguito credo sia seguito
credo comunque se stiamo nel maine uno
lo scopriremo mai quindi direi di
cominciare lega andiamo allora
difficoltà normale difficile incubo
folle io mi butto sul incubo perchè
tanto lo so che non dormo uguale quindi
va bene lo stesso poi non ho capito
ragazzi sia ambientato dopo o primipare
prima se non erro pe non mi ricordo
chiesto tizio prega o bisogno di un paio
di occhiali perché non vedo un cazzo a
prescindere cos'è la volgia ragazzi si
rimorchia così da adesso in avanti
perché sa ma tu sei più sexy ragazzi c'è
gente veramente sexy che mi sta toccando
mettila ritoccarmi il bene ragazzini
palpano questi ciao ai bellissimi occhi
apri gli occhi a testa di merda qual è
il problema qualcuno ti ha colpito
ecco lascia che ti aiuti non mi capitino
una testata che ragazzi pervertito di
merda reja 9 andrews sta ricevendo che
semplici cose sembrano problemi seri al
motore dicono che a bova abbia fatto
un'ascensione laterale billy bob cazzo e
non sono felici no
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo che si
vabbè andiamo ragazzi non non ho capito
un cazzo di quello che ha detto perché
la mia leprato in faccia uno nel karting
fax o madonna che schifo se ti becco
tipico una testa due ore prima io non so
che cosa è successo so soltanto che un
tizio mi ha leccato in faccia e non è
una cosa che non mi conosci devo fare in
fretta fosse mi controllano lavorato da
settimane come consulente informatico
nella clinica psichiatrica murghab nyman
bestie che sarebbe a quella dove c'erano
tutti pazzi sto per infrangere
tonnellate di clausole e va bene un lego
più una stecca ovviamente uno si mette a
scrivere i lunghi cosa fa
in tensione ragazzino io non so perché
una persona dovrebbe scrivere in un
posto del genere io già mi caga ray ad
hoc già visto che arrivando addosso in
camera mia figura tenerli dentro
succedono cose orribili non riesco a
capire anzi non riesco a credere nemmeno
a metà di quello che ho visto i dottori
parlano di una terapia dei sogni che
andata troppo oltre i velando qualcosa e
li aspetta sulla montagna gente soffre
quelli da molto affanno i saldi devono
saperlo tutti ragazzi dal pulsante
sinistro del mouse inviare un'e mail
quindi a tornei chi ce l'abbiamo con
sappiamo sta facendo niente di niente
dopo lo stavo controllando le notifiche
di facebook non c'è problema stai
tranquillo ci siamo mi posso muovere
impossibile sì qui
ah che bello che sei perché ti hanno
fatto mi chiama real cerca persone già
tre volte c'è un'emergenza al motore a
sentiamo nuovo obiettivo per lui
soddisfare del motore morpho james cole
zio tu non sai ke kazzo passato prima mi
hanno leccato in faccia tu non hai idea
di quello che passa ma non importa dove
cazzo siamo asi quest'anno raga questo è
il posto che c'era nel finale di auto la
prima serie sono che ovviamente adesso
adesso ci sono persone dove prima non
c'erano si vede che questo è prima che
succedesse tutto quel casino dalla
padiglioni andare avanti perché dove
cazzo san gallo non lo so neanch'io ma
non importa mondo tu sei veramente in
figure cristo non sbrigati stanno
aspettando ok ho capito ma non c'è la
zona il culo
c'è un attimo madonna la gente qua c'è
uno stile che non avete idea se arrivato
paga il limite ho capito arrivata mi
siedo è mi siedo bene per soli preciso
non si capisce un cazzo
ok ragazzi c'è un tizio nudo c'è un
tizio mondo che si sta portando via la
gente allora io importante che inizi
qualche film così mi distraggo lo sapevo
che stava per succedere i nostri
schifosi
dunque è una cosa sta cosa fa ok il
musical calmo ai dei vecchi appelli alla
cristiano ronaldo ma non importa è una
cosa sta succedendo aiutami non lasciare
che mi facciano questo amico mio mi sono
seduto lì io non è colpa mia barba tutto
bene ad es
ehi tu sei quello che ma le carte in
faccia brutto stronzo ragazzi non torna
al tuo ufficio va bene io sì ho capito
però tu mai legate in faccia lui il
nostro anche una testata pd ora non ha
idea delle mio ufficio poi non mi
ricordi qua io io vado di qui intorno
davvero dover all'inizio in poche parole
sembra che non ci sia qualcuno non c'è
nessun perfetto io non ho ancora capito
perché qualcuno sta facendo la spia
cazzo e va beh [ __ ] però io
metti le mani dove posso vedersi va beh
ma sede strano insieme testa di minchia
di taglio le braccia pura tecnica
ragazzi il signor milan park contratto
di collaborazione esterna deprimente mi
hanno beccato perché ho mandato quella
meglio prima va al cuore
sì però siete stranzi fa il mio computer
forse potrebbe somministrare al signor
pac no no no perché bastardi ragazzi le
buone maniere l'anno lo sapeva medaille
tenuta temi già che ci siete
ulisse flora ragazzi mi hanno leccato la
faccia mi hanno spiattellato 1 nudo sul
vetro mi hanno picchiato è successo di
tutto in cinque minuti non è possibile
va bene ma siamo rimasti dove lo prima e
poi qua e dove mi avevano lasciato la
faccia perfetto successo poi non ho
capito
che è successo si sono libero può saltar
mi posso alzarmi bene e non lo senti
vero c'è un tizio brutto dietro perfetto
mi sa che se n'è accorto ok
bene bene non ho capito che cazzo
successo ma non importa
però a me hanno sempre legato alla
faccia quindi è peggio per me posso
prendere gol grazie a dio
ragazzi ho trovato una videocamera che
almeno con questa fosse finalmente non
mi ricordo come ci si muove ragazzi con
la videocamera però non importa c'era un
tizio brutto che ha ucciso gli altri mi
sa infatti mi sa che c'è un po di sangue
salve sono fessi di essere sicuro lì
timido fiorellino cazzo ti apre in due
noti apro il tua sorella aprendo ti
faccio godere aspettano che cazzo dici
ragazzi quasi tutti i pervertiti ma è
possibile c'è ma solo vinto in un
manicomio di maniaci ragazzi fate
qualcosa vi prego no no no amico mio non
ti grattare il pene si sta vicina
perfetto a cambiare ha cambiato
direzione non avrei capito chi è quel
tizio ma io io vado avanti nel dubbio
quindi non so neanche che cazzo è
successo di preciso
denis law firm oddio che cazzo stampa
c'è ragazzi ok no no gli ho risparmiato
un po di scene ragazzi non importa
facciamo finta di non vedere comunque la
cosa bella visto gioca che solo nudo
giorno ho visto un tizio modo che
correvano
ho sognato sarde un cazzo ok ragazzi
quel tizio quel tizio non è cosa buona
mi sa mère da dove poi vado di qui la
prima porta fra star dove dove dove c'è
un nullo dove è sparito ragazzi è
sparito è sparito il tizio di prima che
mi core comunque ho visto un tizio nudo
io prima e non è che ma state cucinando
qualcosa col ketchup a livello del giro
fatemi capire allora io vado di qua
perché per tizio mi stanno guardando
malissimo
c'è il tizio nudo che corre ma
ripensandoci torno indietro e allora
fatemi capire che cosa accadde so devo
fare che non ho capito ma si può entrare
di quanto scontrano ma io non entrerei
qua dentro a pub esposte sono costretto
si sono entrato lo sei il nostro tom
sbircio ne viene a partecipare alla
nostra sessione di terapia e allora
guarda io l'affettato non lo gradisce si
ringrazia ho detto che non lo gradisco
preferisco la pasta finita la maschia ma
un po nel nostro amico qui ma non voglio
scavare nel dottore senti ma a parte una
terapia facciale pure tu se ti trattieni
per troppo tempo potresti fare qualcosa
di cui ti penti non sei uno di quelli
troppo buono partiti come noi avesse di
essere differente speciale ma io uscirei
volentieri esco con piacere fuori siete
molto giunti a una cosa prima però prima
di uscire due amici che stavo bay
ragazzi possiamo uscire definitivamente
chiudo anche la porta sono un gentleman
ben pensato ok non me l'ha ascoltata
dove cazzeggia [ __ ] c'è chi come ti
permetti stronza ragazzi sono stati
abbinati a fan culo pezzenti di merda
che cazzo successo di un chiudi perfetto
dove dove possa andare prima che tutti
si apra la porta dove posso andare di
qua ragazzi che mou sia esse di qui a un
ok che culo o trovata [ __ ] perfetto
ragazzi fa altro che solid snake
qua siamo in out la sa ancora peggio mi
sono preso il cazzo di bard pessima idea
andiamo alla reception
non sappiamo neanche se la radio
funziona ragazzi quelli sono sani di
mente
quindi sono cattivi raggiungi la radio
nella prigione allora addio raggiungere
la radio per chiamare a sé per chiamare
aiuto perfetto che sono nella merda in
poche parole lui prende la
responsabilità di ogni cosa legalmente
discutibile essendosi già che c'è un
tizio a terra la cosa promette malissimo
ma non in poi uscendo se ti alzi che
azzurro che tt lancio su sul termosifone
che c'è qui fatemi uscire prima che quel
tizio li prendo male perché non lo so no
no ho detto che devi stare seduto
sentivi in these are back metti tv dove
sta il prima perché non mi piace la cosa
che ti sei alzato il braccio non si è
incazzato e questo va già bene dove devo
andare riportava duri quando li faccia
effetto ha chiuso da chiusa la porta
[Applauso]
cazzo succede ragazzi e di modulo
spettro cazzo e cos'era sto rumore che
non mi è piaciuto per niente
vado di qua prima che succeda qualcosa
di brutto ok non so dove sarà a
buongiorno senta lei bell'uomo aiutami
ti prego sono un dottore è dovuto andare
a casa dai miei ma [ __ ] non sei
nella sicurezza io ero sono impaziente
come te ma vaffan quanti credono mai
però ti apro lo stesso perché sono buono
d'animo ed enti meriti ti presento il
mio amico amico mio allora questa è vino
incontrato prima è un tipo molto
socievole molto simpatico l'ho già
parlato un paio di volte ragazzi si
stanno divertendo e metro si divertono
io andrei avanti di preciso grazie prego
non lo so intanto ci sono degli
armadietti così se succede qualcosa
posso nascondermi non so che cazzo
succede ma torno indietro la sicurezza
ok ragazzi non so che a cazzo sta
succedendo di preciso ma cos'è cos'è e
cosa stato
no no eh ma allora si bastardo ma
[ __ ]
come ha fatto a trovarmi ma vado
nell'altro vaffan cuore non hanno
sbagliato tasto sbagliato fottutamente
tasto entra qui no è che chi cazzo
ragazzi non c'è verso
senta io sono qui per caso e io vado di
cuadrado di buongiorno ragazze non so
neanche come cazzo fatto scappare ma
molliamo ci manca quel tizio mi
raggiunga vedi qua di qua si ok questo
stato sono soprattutto che non so
neanche come cazzo fatto salorino non ne
arriva un altro ne arriva un altro cosa
già uno ne basta è borsano di mano cube
no l'uscita [ __ ] ema sete stronzi
forte però dai dove devo andare ragazzi
che ho perso ho perso tutto non c'è più
una porta male iniziata forse di qua no
di qua è chiuso a ecco perfetto devo
fare devo fare tipo assassin's creed
dopo essere sopra le è perfetta ma è
così perché se noi non usiamo le porte
usiamo tutt'altro siccome ragazzi non
ancora capito dove sto andando perché
l'entrata era dall'altra parte madonna
questa sta messa peggio di me sta gente
o non importa andiamo avanti lo stesso e
tu chi cazzo sei grazie a quel tizio
legame benissimo mi dovete spiegare
perché sto andando da quel piano sta
cucinando ma dirlo subito ma che
patiscono piatto anch'io grazie vediamo
se cosa sta facendo
ragazze usciamo di qui prima che quello
lì si piglia male non spettava ragazzi
posso guardarlo davanti
ok forse è meglio di no forse è meglio
di no io torni indietro grazie mille non
guardarci lo sa lo amo ma anche bello
quando una persona dal cuore ad un altro
ecco perfetto come non detto
e se proprio mi sa che lui ha preso un
po troppo alla lettera la faccenda del
dammi il tuo cuore ti amerò per sempre
no non mi piace solo maroni che c'è lo
spettro vero dimmi che non c'è lo
spettro perché non c'ho voglia di
correre
non c'è lo spettro perfetto che ce l'ho
fatta penso se penso sia al sicuro poi
arrampicati chi è che ce l'ha fatta
aprite aprite stragiudiziale non avevo
neanche vista bisogna togliere manette a
questa porta dove dovrei trovare le
chiavi fatemi capire a tassi puoi
passare qua per te è veramente io dalle
ragazze dall uscita potrebbe uscire così
ragazzi c'è il tizio di prima che era
innamorato quello che mi ha visto
l'aspetto allora come non detto come non
detto
come non detto come non detto usciamo
ragazzi dico non ci arriva di pancia
arrivati con saliva su kart su un po
vorrei puntualizzare sul fatto che c'è
un qualcosa in mano che mi pare
vagamente un dildo un po grosso ma non
gli porta fiori di riuscire a fare un
qualcosa di decente sono inciampato sul
letto un genio cit inciampare su un
letto mentre su un tizio con una
motosega in mano e diamo di chiarirci
bene le idee semi rincorri madonna
quante legnate non ho mai visto tu non
hai visto tu non mi hai visto bravo è
passato di qua io io corro corro mai
così a caso eccoti qui carne ma
[ __ ] carne sarà tua sorella
ma dove stiamo andando non lo so apri
apri qualcosa chiudi veloce ok
bene bene bene no guarda nella maglietta
del marito
io tantissimo ho fatto apposta
forse già fatto ragazzini che sfonda
aperto la porta
posso sentire il tuo odore non è vero io
profumo di chanel
ok tutto l'altro aperto un altro che
quali mamma non aperto il mio ma aperto
il mio cazzo ma che palle però è
[ __ ] 6 mezzo di mia suocera ciccia
ragazze non c'è verso mi trova ovunque
dove dovete man dove devo andare
vedo un cazzo regala non vedo un cazzo
chiude chiudi il mio dio mio dio dove
stiamo andando li precede chiuso merda e
vabbè [ __ ] però qui sotto mi stato
usato ok calmi calmi anni ok ci siamo a
dei ragazzi io direi che posso
concludere qui per questo episodio
perché è successo di tutto praticamente
niente raga io continuerò nel prossimo
devi sapere ragazzi con un commento se
vi è piaciuto al video comunque se vi è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche al vasari facebook e come noi
video tratte nella descrizione senatori
city iscrivetevi ci vediamo al prossimo
vinto da ragazzi
[Musica]